dass der Hamburger Hafen großes Stück
Deutschland und Teile davon werden jetzt
verkauft an China der Mensch das ist
deutsche Geschichte Handel Wohlstand das
Tor zur Welt dafür steht er der
Hamburger Hafen stand der Hamburger
Hafen jetzt tatsächlich wird ein großer
Teil davon verkauft an China
ein großer Teil des Hamburger Hafens
ganz genau
24,9 Prozent des Hamburger Hafen
Terminals gehen also ja an das Land in
Fernost ein skandalverkauf ein Skandal
Deal der jetzt gerade in diesem Minuten
durch Kabinett gewunken wurde ja Olaf
Scholz hat sich da also durchgesetzt das
Tor zur Welt das ist der Hamburger Hafen
für China bald auch das Einfallstor zu
unserer kritischen Infrastruktur bei uns
im Studio ist jetzt Peter Thiede unser
Bild Chefreporter mit dir wollen wir
natürlich darüber reden es war eine Art
friss oder stirbt Spiel von Olaf Scholz
scheint als hätte er sich jetzt am Ende
durchgesetzt wie hat er das hinbekommen
also sortieren wir mal der Hamburger
Hafen hat vier Terminals einen Container
Turm Terminal geht nach China die wir zu
einem Viertel es waren ursprünglich
geplant 35%. diese 35% wollte das
Wirtschaftsministerium komplett
verändern sechs wichtige Ministerien in
der Bundesregierung waren dagegen
ausdrücklich darunter auch die Bundes
auch die Nachrichtendienste der
Auslandsnachrichtendienst der
Inlandsnachrichtendienst die CH lauthals
gewarnt vor die jetzt mit mit China nur
Olaf Scholz wollte dass der frühere
Hamburger Oberbürgermeister das ist
Scholz chinaschande der hat jetzt dafür
gesorgt dass man keine Vollversorgung
macht so heißt was der Bund darf gegen
ein solches Geschäft ein Veto einlegen
das wollte der Wirtschaftsminister das
wollte die Außenministerin das wollten
die Minister für Verkehr Inneres und für
Finanzen ebenfalls und Scholz hat dann
gesagt Leute ich setze einfach keine
vito-entscheidung auf die Liste auf die
Tagesordnung für das Kabinett und
stattdessen hat er dann angeboten einen
faulen Kompromiss weil es wirklich ein
Aufstand gab wir machen aus 35%
24,9 Prozent ohne irgendwelche
Sperrminorität und die Chinesen dürfen
dann auch kein Personal bestimmen
irgendwie keine strategischen
Entscheidung erzwingen aber rausgehalten
hat der China nicht und das
bemerkenswerte ist der Bundespräsident
der früher immer die Russland die jetzt
durchgewunken hatte dafür verantwortlich
war hat gestern Abend in der Tagesschau
gewarnt verschiedener Deals der Kanzler
macht das jetzt und damit den Fehler
gemacht ihn war früher mit Russland
gemacht haben stoppt diesen Deal hat
Bild heute ganz groß auf Seite 2
geschrieben und da drunter den Kanzler
gesetzt wir sehen das hier noch mal als
chinesische Marionette Peter warum
weil wir uns fragen müssen für wen
öffnet der Kanzler hier warum das Tor
wir sehen da unten da waren noch ein
kleines Foto eingeblendet da war Frau
Schwesig und das hatten wir im April
gemacht Frau Schwesig die
Ministerpräsidentin vom
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die sich so
auffällig doll für Russland eingesetzt
hat und für Gaspipelines aus Russland
damals war die die marinette von hinten
Ski und man muss sich wirklich fragen
wenn sechs wichtige Ministerien wenn
alle wirklich alle Experten außerhalb
des Bundeskanzleramtes davor gewarnt
haben diesen Deal zu machen und nur ein
kleines Stückchen deutscher
Infrastruktur nach China zu geben warum
der Bundeskanzler dann dagegen
entschieden hat warum macht oder Scholz
das warum macht Olaf Scholz den Fehler
den Frau Merkel und Herr Schröder mit
Russland gemacht haben jetzt
ausgerechnet mit China von dem der Chef
des Bundesnachrichtendienst sagt das ist
wesentlich schlimmer und noch
gefährlicher als Russland
müssen jetzt die Hafen Mitarbeiter in
Hamburg Chinesisch lernen oder welche
Folgen vom nights auf vor allem die
Hamburger Hafen Mitarbeiter
44 Container Terminals sind es und es
geht ja an cosco das ist wirklich eine
logistikrake staatlicher also eine
staatliche logistikrake Chinas und
Costco ist heute schon einer der
wichtigsten Kunden im Hamburger Hafen
und die kaufen sich jetzt ein Viertel
vom von diesem einen von diesem
einteilen man muss sich fragen warum
wenn man auf die Weltkarte guckt wenn
man sich nur die Europakarte und guckt
wo kauft China überall Infrastruktur
dann sehen wir das ist eine einzige Ecke
in Europa gibt wo sie noch keinen Hafen
haben und das ist nämlich ganz im Norden
das ist bei uns wir haben in
antwerpenbinder als Beteiligung
Rotterdam Minderheitsbeteiligung und
alle Experten sagen Leute China geht
strategisch vor China macht nicht
einfach Wirtschaftspolitik China ist
Imperial ist eine imperiale macht die
erobern die sichern sich ihre
Handelswege um am um auch uns im Zweifel
die Wege versperren zu können ein Stück
des Hamburger Hafens wird jetzt Ch mal
gehören das hat das Kabinett heute
beschlossen dazu unser bildchefreporter
Peter Tiet danke dir
[Musik]